TO ONCE AGAIN IGNITE THE REGION.
>> Mike: THE NEW YEAR BEGINS
WITH A HOST OF FOREIGN POLICY
CHALLENGES FOR A TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FACING AN
IMPEACHMENT BATTLE HERE AT HOME.
RICH SETS THE TABLE FOR A BUSY
2020 OVERSEAS.
>> SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO'S FIRST TRIP OF THE NEW
YEARS OFF.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAID
MONITORING EVENTS IN IRAQ AND
THE ASSAULT ON THE U.S. EMBASSY
IN BAGHDAD WILL KEEP THE SECT IN
WASHINGTON.
>> I WILL BE IN THE RIGHT PLACE
TO ENSURE THAT OUR PEOPLE AND
AMERICANS ARE SAFE AND SURE IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> OFFICIALS WARN THE SANCTIONS
CAMPAIGN AGAINST IRAN IN 2019
WILL CONTINUE IN 2020.
IRAN IS ONE OF SEVERAL FOREIGN
POLICY CHALLENGES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FACES IN THE NEW
YEAR.
THE ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO
BUILD ON ITS SUCCESSES.
DEMOCRATS SAY THERE IS MOSTLY
FAILURE.
>> IN A WEAKNESS OF HIS FOREIGN
POLICY WHICH WE HAVE SEEN NOT
JUST IN THE MIDDLE EAST BUT WITH
RESPECT TO RUSSIA AND CHINA AND
NORTH KOREA.
>> NORTH KOREA KIM JONG-UN IS
THREATENING TO UNVEIL A NEW
WEAPON.
>> HE LIKES ME AND I LIKE HIM.
WE GET ALONG.
WE HAVE TO DO WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO.
>> KIM SAID HIS COUNTRY IS NO
LONGER CONTRAINED BY HIS
AGREEMENT WITH THE PRESIDENT TO
HALT NUCLEAR TESTS.
THE U.S. TRIED FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF TO GET NORTH KOREA TO
DISMANTLE ITS WEAPONS.
KIM PROMISES TO MOVE FURTHER
AWAY FROM A DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT IS READY TO SIGN
PHASE-1 A TRADE AGREEMENT WITH
CHINA IN 2 WEEKS THERE ARE A
HOST OF ECONOMIC AND HUMAN
RIGHTS DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE 2
COUNTRIES.
THE U.S. SUPPORTED DEMOCRATIC
PROTESTORS IN HONG KONG.
THERE IS THE PROSPECT OF A PEACE
DEAL WITH THE TALIBAN IN
AFGHANISTAN.
DIFFERENCES OR COOPERATION WITH
RUSSIA.
A UKRAINE CENTERED IMPEACHMENT
TRAIL AND ALL ELSE EXPECTED FROM
AN UNPREDICTABLE PRESIDENT.
>> Mike: THERE IS TENSION ACROSS
THE TREAT.
>> CERTAINLY ON FOREIGN POLICY.
ONE OF THE HALLMARKS OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS A
STRONGER RELATIONSHIP WITH SAUDI
ARABIA TO PROVIDE A GREATER
CHECK ON IRAN.
THERE IS A LOT THATS THAT GONE
ON IN THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
SAUDI ARABIA THE KILLING OF